why you should learn how to analyze your
Cloud billing costs with bigquery Cloud
billing enables you to export detailed
Google cloud and Google Maps billing
data to bigquery automatically
throughout the day data like usage cost
cost estimate and pricing it's
comparable to checking your bank
statement to see what you've been
spending on the last month you can
access your exported Cloud billing data
in bigquery for detailed analysis of
your Cloud costs you can even further
analyze your data with a tool like
looker Studio to visualize the data
here's a tutorial so you can practice
doing this you'll create a billing admin
project to hold your billing data create
a bigquery data set to hold the exported
data in enable the billing data to
export to that bigquery data set and run
some sample queries through the bigquery
web interface to examine the exported
Cloud billing data make sure to
subscribe to learn about more tutorials
like this one and now you know